I got to pitch my show to Jubilee last
year and I gotta make it and it was so
much fun Jubilee just came out with the
Creator launch pad an opportunity where
you can submit your show to Jubilee and
get paid for it click the link in the
description below for more information I
live in a house with all my best friends
we're all Polly you stay right where you
are
[Music]
hello everyone hello so that's that's
most so you can stay there
okay I'm good all right I'm nice in the
middle is that what you're saying I
think you have to take a a little walk
over there oh me do I look like that
much of a okay
notice she she didn't say anything she
just moved quickly yeah yeah
I feel like I uh kind of fly under the
radar people always assume I'm I'm CIS
and straight and people tend to be a
little surprised based on my
conservative outfit Choice I'm gonna
move myself one all right
good good I just want to make sure even
though you're Incognito I just
I feel like I just think I think you
should actually go right back oh my God
all right all right okay I think that's
okay okay okay nice shoes you know thank
you yeah
I didn't pick these so somebody else in
my life is clearly somebody else in your
life somebody else
right
how do we feel about the lineup I think
it's good
I have no opinion on on where you should
be then you need you should probably
move one yeah one one yeah that's all
right team there you go I think we're
good yeah this feels good
[Music]
when did you all first know that you
were polyamorous the day I was born
I like where you are in the line out of
all the relationships that I'd ever been
in no matter who I was with
um I would always have feelings for
someone else so I knew kind of young I
didn't actually come out as Polly up
until about two or three years ago so I
want to say it's still kind of new to me
but every day is really a learning
experience when did I start to figure
that out when I took anthropology in
college and they explained what um
persianism was what is a so it's the joy
you get from experiencing somebody
else's Joy yes my gosh guys
every relationship I'd had since that
moment was me trying to talk about it
and it not being correct you know it's
like we know it's the first group I've
ever been in where everybody goes yes
everybody else goes no we don't if I was
a serial monogamist it just kind of
transformed slowly Partners were on
board so
yeah there's this expectation that
you're supposed to be selfish when
you're in a relationship and that is
just never computed with me I would say
it's about like been a year and a half
two years of like me when I'm dating I'm
like yeah this is what I do this is yeah
welcome I think you go up yeah Direction
all right switch with me okay oh
oh
oh okay all right you might be able to
move up yeah yeah I live in a house with
all my best friends
we're all Polly you're all Polly yeah I
love that you stay right where you are
do you guys need a new roommate I bet
they're my best I just said they're my
besties like how much free time would
you say you have for all of my partners
uh there's not enough time but I give
most of my time to my current primary
yeah she just all all
as I will say most of my time is used by
work I just work entirely too much so oh
I feel okay so yeah but back come back
what am I going right here yeah yeah
doing a lot of Shifting around in the
middle over here yeah oh gosh yeah no I
do not have an inch of times partly
because I'm still trying to figure out
my own time management trying to balance
that with other people has been allowed
in Kev free agent I'm gonna I'm gonna
scooch
scooch this way then I feel like I have
some from some time are your partners
Paulie ah yes yes that would be crazy
you can you can be Polly and date
monogamous yeah I wouldn't wait until
you've dated a monogamous person being
Paulie yeah yeah like they're monogamous
they don't want to date anyone
themselves in our relationship and it
like that line is not exactly exactly
exactly you literally could not pay me
to be monogamous ever again I think it's
a trap what about careers I'm a comedian
oh yeah
yeah
I get some okay I make music
why did we take the anchor out music
above comedy rock star above anybody who
makes jokes I am a professional
Dominatrix and a professional sex worker
I am an influencer and I'm a voice actor
word
I just feel like you have more partners
my question is how long is your longest
relationship
18 years what wow wow I find that when I
talk to monogamous people about like
because people are always curious I mean
usually they're curious for a reason but
um
I'll start talking to them about it and
like a lot of the stuff that we say
align like being honest with my partner
or like how I want to live my life or
how I want to like choose every day to
commit to someone and make that like an
active Choice as opposed to like own
someone and control someone like a lot
of those things in the dating world like
my friends that are monogamous that date
around like all of the same complaints
that they have are the ones that I have
as well and like the thing the qualities
that they're looking in a like for in a
partner like we just go about it in a
different way you over here I was gonna
say the same yeah interesting that's
yeah you might be in the beginning
stages that freshness means that there's
you know more experimentation I don't
know people think that we're all Polly
just to like have sex and that's really
not what it's about at all like it's
more about like that deeper connection
with someone else anyone have any
opinions on me
So based on everybody here everybody is
really friendly and open and exciting
and easy to be and I'm less so no you
are no no no
sorry
nobody's keep going I'm just bullying
you know I apologize for this
interaction I think you should move
closer this way
why am I still here
no yeah I think that's right that's
better that's better all right all right
yeah you're gonna tell us what to do now
cool cool why don't you just tell us
where we should go how about that I'll
leave me I only said one thing how do
you deal with the feelings of jealousy I
will say that it is a complete myth that
is a polyamorous person you do not
experience jealousy that is and
if you are looking to be in a
polyamorous relationship because you
think there is no jealousy you're lying
to yourself you know the old thing with
the monogamous people talk about breakup
sex breakup sex the monogamous Community
gets mad at each other they have a fight
and they're like I'm never and then they
have sex I was like you know you could
just talk about those feelings get it
riled up and then do it you don't have
to break up with each other if you don't
if you don't pipe into that every once
in a while I feel bad for you jealousy
like teaches me about myself because I I
think when I was monogamous if I had a
jealous feeling then I would put that on
my partner and I would say you're doing
something wrong to make me feel jealous
as opposed to now when I'm like okay I'm
experiencing jealousy like what is that
am I feeling insecure is there something
that's actually going on in this
relationship that I need to talk to them
about but like I never put the onus on
the other person for my feelings I also
think jealousy is hot I mean see yes are
you are you listening you can get you
can enjoy this yeah
you know I'm feeling good I'm moving to
myself
I think we need to swap too because you
move yourself I feel like you have to
move again
oh I don't like it up here in the top
as somebody who is um uh identifies
heterosexual
I'm sorry please continue please yeah
yeah I I didn't know I said that wrong I
apologize if I'm no no no oh you're good
okay you said it perfectly
um
it is interesting as being Paulie now
that uh you can see somebody who's
attracted to your partner and who is
your gender and who are you are not
attracted to but suddenly feel like oh
we have a level of intimacy that I've
never had with another friend and you
and the level of discussion I can now
have with that male is something that
most heterosexual men have never
experienced yeah the level of knowledge
and and empathy that comes out of that
would cure a lot of the heterosexual
problems oh I mean think about all the
violence that's attached in in spousal
abuse and relationships of that nature
it's it's all based on jealousy and fear
and all that stuff and if you could just
really be open with it
yeah what a take I love that take I love
that thing well it's it's the the root
it's the root of a lot of problems but I
never understood I'm gonna beat this
as I asked her with my man why
you're going after like you weren't
dating her like I'm not you're gonna
move one more you're now our anchor it's
just for the sake
[Music]
that's right I've just not been paying
attention for the last 10 minutes I'm
like what am I doing here you are anchor
here up here at the top I feel the
pressure how do we feel about marriage
oh uh uh I feel like marriage is just
like a business contract like it doesn't
really apply to me like I don't really
need to do it is anybody currently
married
does that change anything is that a
hickey on your neck
yeah well I think hickey goes up yeah I
think Nikki moves okay
how do we feel wait I'm moving
I think we're good I think we're good I
think we did some discovery
Anya
[Music]
being individuals who just don't believe
me that aren't in the community
themselves but they think that I'm
saying it because it's cool or trendy
fifth we have dinasia with one partner
what have you done my mind
I just need to shut up I hate you so
much in fourth we have Jacob with two
partners oh wow and third we actually
have a tie Justin also with two partners
oh
oh wow second Mia three partners
and in first Jacks with five Partners
very good at least we had one
[Music]
you're our girlfriend
you now have five Partners you didn't
know that you're actually you're
actually okay
yeah I'm usually in at least two
relationships so I'm just in one right
now all right you're close all right all
right so we weren't fine I'm in two
relationships right now
um I've been seeing my boyfriend for
about a year and my other partner for
about five uh my wife and I have been
married for uh
I'll be
uh 13 years 10 years 10 years 10 years
next year and we've been together for
17. and about eight years ago my wife
came out to me as bi and she said I've
actually had a crush on your college
friend that's on your Facebook five
years ago we dm'd her on Instagram and
uh we moved her out six months later to
uh live with us in Los Angeles and we've
been together ever since okay so I
practice solo polyamory and so the way I
Define a partner for me is someone that
I like continually keep informed and
expect them to do the same to me so for
me personally I have intimate partners
and I have partners that I see as a
dominatrix that I have intimate
relationships with uh so I have a
question outside of the your partners
um who has other people that they're
dating
there are like two like three so
like so before oh I'm not dating anyone
else outside of my current relationships
yeah I'm not dating anybody outside my
current relationships with my two
partners so I'm crying
like a lot like I'm going on a date
after this I love that for you I date
around a lot like I said I was assigned
hoe at Birth so that's my story really
good morning
[Music]